if you had a family member you'd want
them to date the best person for them
yep
are you winning for Justin and Selena
I'm rooting for anybody I know to find
somebody that makes them better and that
goes across the board to you know my
children someday I'm a look at that yes
is that a yes I but I mean I I could
speak about them individually do I want
Justin to find somebody that's gonna
make him better and have him you know
live a fulfilled fruitful life yes I
think Selena Gomez is amazing and I'm
hoping that she continues to thrive and
flourish and be a legend absolutely yeah
is there a point where you'll stop
answering questions about Justin and
Selena and I kind of let them dictate
that as far as what they're comfortable
with do you have that conversation with
them out of respect are you like hey
just oh yeah for sure
and I think you know most of the time
it's a no comment anyway it's not even
an issue but they're both so awesome and
doing so well that none of the stuff
we're saying is private of course we're
answering questions that are you know at
least it would you know commonly
misinterpreted in English when did you
first meet Justin Bieber uh when he was
like 13 14 oh you met him not long ago
yeah yeah known him for a while how
would you describe your relationship
with him um he's a really good friend
probably more like a family member to me
then then like a guy that I know cuz
I've seen you know his journey and he's
really uh easing he's an awesome guy to
be around
as someone who obviously said they
consider him family to see him going
through some of the things he's been
through how do you sit back and lend a
helping hand but also ensure that he's
okay
I think the object of serving somebody
as a friend is to hear you first try to
figure out what you need the most and
fit into that so the same way I would do
it with any other friend and I'm not
trying to get my point across or try to
give heavy-handed advice
I think I'm trying to be a voice of
reason when needed and I'd say more
often than not I'm just playing off of
whatever he needs at the time as of late
he's been like you know for someone
who's as young as him and has as much
access as he does yeah he's like an
angel and and a lot of people the
tabloids are that's the good thing about
getting in trouble with it when you live
like not bad and some of the tabloids
are saying that he's running a lot of
his decisions by you and you're kind of
helping him yeah the person he's 100%
misplaced credit okay that boy gets
credit for his own life changed so
justin marked this new chapter in his
life by being baptized carl performed
the sacred ceremony in NBA player Tyson
Chandler's bathtub and talks about the
experience in his new book owned the
moment in the book you know you talk
about Justin reaching out to you wanting
to be baptized how did that how did that
come about the reason why I put that in
the book is because there's a lot of
stories written about him and even
during that time there were a lot of
false narratives right as we sit here
today we could find at least a dozen
stories that just didn't happen so about
his baptism was a chance to point people
to something bigger which is the needs
that we all have in common so yeah he's
mega famous
but even famous people have pretty much
the same needs as we do we need love we
need friendship we need to be challenged
and his baptism moment was something it
was personal but yet he's been kind
enough to allow it to be something that
reminds everybody if you really want
something bad enough you got to make it
happen